if you want to start a company and need
money to do it you usually pitch a
venture capitalist
i've raised over 100 million dollars for
my two startups
and essentially all of that money came
from vcs
but now everything's changing venture
capitalists have long been the masters
of silicon valley
with their casual outfits low slung
offices on sandhill road
and sometimes outsized personalities and
fancy cars
guys in this town don't have the balls
to drive a car like this they're
billionaires
and they drive [ __ ] priuses why but
what if it wasn't this way
what if a bigger fish entered the
startup funding world
and completely ate the venture
capitalist lunch with a new and
disruptive funding model
what would happen to all these vcs and
their amazing returns
tiger global is a hedge fund that
recently dove headfirst into startup
funding
and is now announcing a new deal every
48 hours
they're beating venture capitalists at
their own game and winning deals left
and right
but how are they doing it when you think
of hedge funds you probably think of
rich guys in fancy suits
barking orders into phones and causing
massive swings in the public markets
but the term hedge fund is actually
quite fluid
i don't know what a hedge fund is i i
really don't know
some people are value investors some
people invest in bonds
some people invest in stocks people do
all different things within a structure
called a hedge fund
that's ray dalio the founder of
bridgewater associates
which is the world's largest hedge fund
and even he doesn't know how to define
the term precisely
that's because at the end of the day a
hedge fund is just a pool of capital
that aims to make the best possible
returns for its investors
and in 2021 the best returns are coming
from technology startups
traditionally hedge funds have operated
primarily in public markets
buying and selling shares of public
traded companies like apple and facebook
but in the past few months there has
been a massive wave of hedge funds
crossing over into private markets and
pouring billions of dollars into
startups before they go public
tiger global is the biggest of these
so-called crossover funds
and they do all of their deals from this
skyscraper in new york city
even though they aren't headquartered in
silicon valley they've become the
biggest venture capital firm
seemingly overnight so what does tiger
know about venture capital investing
that all of the traditional vcs don't
let's dig into their strategy to find
out
tiger global was started by this guy
chase coleman
the firm has been posting incredible
returns for the last two decades
in fact they've only lost money twice
but they keep an extremely low profile
most silicon valley investors do
podcasts
talk to the press or at least maintain a
blog but coleman is extremely secretive
in fact this is the only picture of him
available on the internet
and he's never been quoted directly in
any press story
i had to learn more about chase coleman
and how he became the biggest venture
capital investor
seemingly overnight so i analyzed every
deal he's done in silicon valley to boil
his strategy down to three key points
everyone knows that hedge funds have a
lot of money tiger alone manages more
than 30 billion dollars
and coleman himself has amassed a
multi-billion dollar fortune of his own
but more on that later even though hedge
funds have always had the capital to
make big bets
they have traditionally focused on
public markets where plenty of financial
data is available
and they have the option to go long or
short based on their assessment of a
particular company
but tiger has developed a unique edge
when it comes to identifying
fast-growing startups
and this is their first key advantage
tiger has optimized
the research and due diligence process
when an investor meets a company
they typically have a series of meetings
to get to know the founders
learn about the market and understand
the financials this often takes
weeks and even after the investor is
ready to make the investment
the company will still need to spend
more time going through a due diligence
process that involves turning over
extra financial information and having
long calls with lawyers
tiger has optimized this whole process
so they can move faster than traditional
vcs
despite doing more deals than andreessen
horowitz this year they have
one third the head count on their
investing team everett randall who's a
vc at founders fund
recently explained their outsourcing
process this way but
it starts with outsourcing so they
outsource basically anything that is not
an investment decision and so for
research
you know they hire consultants i think
it's bain and so baine is just coming to
them every month and is saying hey
here's this market that you know all
these good vc's just invested in here's
every single competitor
here's all the emails of the ceo here's
everything that you need to know and
then also on like the nda diligence i
think they have
you know probably like an army of
lawyers to do all that you can kind of
just go in meet a founder say hey i want
to see x y and z
and then you can kind of make the
decision right there this has a big
impact on founders
i've had first meetings with tiger folks
that feel like partner meetings with
traditional vc firms
they show up completely prepared and
know everything about your business and
the market already
so things move quite quickly there have
been plenty of other big investors who
have come to silicon valley with
billions of dollars
and made very impulsive investments so
that can't be the only important factor
in tiger's success
wework famously pulled in a four billion
dollar investment from softbank
based on a single 28-minute meeting but
that turned out to be a disaster
closing a big investment extremely
quickly like that is kind of like a
shotgun wedding
both parties involved are going to be
working together for years
so it's important to be aligned but
that's where tiger's second key
advantage comes in
they offer great terms to companies
instead of requiring a board seat
and negotiating for extra control of the
company they trust growth stage
companies to just continue what's
working
when you're just starting out landing a
big investor and having them join your
board
can be incredibly valuable they will
help you strategize and grow your
company
this is often referred to as value-add
investing
but at the growth stage it gets harder
and harder to add real value
when you're running a company that's
making a hundred million dollars selling
a product
there's a good chance that you are a
world expert in that market
a new investor who hasn't run a company
in that market at that scale
might not be able to add that much value
the founder of wework eventually got
into a massive battle with softbank
and that board seat turned out to be
really important
by not requiring a board seat founders
of companies who take money from tiger
don't have to worry about whether or not
they will disagree about the direction
of the company in the future
the ability to have more control over
your business is important
but at the growth stage of your business
there's more at stake
anyone who gets an investment from tiger
has a clear path to going public
but the ipo process is often tumultuous
early investors want to sell their
stakes which are sometimes worth
billions of dollars but tiger is used to
owning public equities
so they don't sell immediately like
other funds this is a great thing for
your company
it means that your stock price is less
likely to fall after you go public
because your investors aren't
immediately selling their shares
this is all good news for entrepreneurs
but quick due diligence and good terms
can't alone win an investor every deal
and that's why tiger's third key
strategy is so important
they aren't afraid to overpay by the
time you're ready to raise a hundred
million dollars for your business
you've already probably done a seed
round a series a
and maybe even a series b it's common
for founders to own less than half their
company at this stage
so when tiger offers a big check that
only requires
10 ownership instead of 20 it's a great
deal
but how can tiger afford to overpay to
win deals
and still earn high returns on the fund
the answer ties in perfectly with
tiger's other key strategies speed by
deploying capital much faster than the
competition
they can accept low returns and still
make more money
a typical venture fund might raise a
billion dollars and then deploy it over
three years
if they are able to earn 3x money on
money returns
this will yield nearly 700 million
dollars in gains per year
but tiger is taking a more aggressive
approach they deploy a full billion
dollars every year
and even though they accept a lower
return of 2x money on money
they wind up making more money one
billion dollars per year
you can see this strategy in action with
tiger's investment in coinbase
it originally looked like they overpaid
but they wound up making a killing when
coinbase went public
this rethinking of the venture capital
equation flies in the face of everything
traditional venture investors believe
but unfortunately for these vcs their
preconceived notions of how the venture
world
should work don't seem to hold up in
practice everett randall
compares tiger's strategy to that of
brawn in game of thrones
during a trial by combat braun has to
fight servartus to the death
on behalf of tyrion lannister servartus
is a traditional knight
bound by the rules of honor and duty to
the crown
he fights braun head-on and expects
braun to abide by the unwritten rules of
noble combat
but brawn knows that this would be a
losing battle so he uses every possible
strategy to get an edge
jumping over railings and dancing around
until cervardis is exhausted and he can
strike a fatal blow
in the end the court is outraged but all
that matters
is that brawn was victorious you don't
fight with honor no
he did this is what's happening in
venture right now
tiger is breaking all the rules and it
seems to be working
but what does this mean for startups
fortunately only good things
if you're running a growth stage company
and looking for tens or even hundreds of
millions of dollars to expand your
business on the path to going public
just having tiger in the market at all
will make your fundraising process much
smoother
even if they don't fund you directly
other funds will have to move quickly
and offer good terms
because they are living in fear of
losing deals to tiger
now most people aren't at that stage yet
and that's totally fine
but you're probably asking yourself if
this trend is good for early stage
entrepreneurs
or even people just starting to think
about launching their first venture
the good news is that a rising tide
lifts all boats in this situation
the additional capital the tiger is
bringing to the late stage market
has made earlier stage investors more
aggressive angel investors know that if
they find the right company and the
business starts taking off
there will be plenty of support from
later stage investors like tiger
to help the company scale well past a
billion dollar valuation
the only people who this really hurts
are the traditional late stage investors
that tiger competes with for deals
everett randall works for founders fund
which was started by peter thiel and has
a legendary track record
entrepreneurs will still want to work
with top tier firms like that
because they actually have a powerful
brand but there is a whole category of
firms whichever called
jc penny funds they don't have fancy
brands
but they also don't offer the walmart
style experience that tiger can give
entrepreneurs increasingly these
jcpenney funds are getting squeezed
and driesn horowitz is building a
massive media arm to differentiate
themselves
and there are no signs of tiger slowing
down their pace
so firm stuck in the middle will likely
struggle to win deals over the next few
years
but what about chase coleman the founder
of tiger global and the leader of this
venture capital revolution
i for one hope he starts opening up a
bit and doing the occasional interview
but for now we'll just have to settle
for gawking at the insane properties
that the tiger team is buying up in palm
beach florida if you'd like to chat with
me about this video
just leave me a comment below or message
me on twitter and please check out this
recommended video
the youtube algorithm thinks that you'll
really like it
you